[Música]
el presidente de Nicaragua Daniel Ortega
recibió al canciller ruso de sergeila
brofen Managua Ortega la profe y sus
delegaciones se dieron cita en el centro
de convenciones sólo fue Palmer de la
capital después de este encuentro habló
con los medios de comunicación y destacó
los estrechos vínculos entre Rusia y
Nicaragua se encuentra la Europa
actualmente de girada por sus países
aliados de América Latina ya se reunió
con el presidente de Brasil Luis Ignacio
Lula da Silva con el presidente de
Venezuela Nicolás maduro y ahora
visitará Cuba este jueves la
conversación sobre este tema es con
esaira Badillo Castro ella es
historiadora de schooler Oriental and
african studiese de la Universidad de
Londres Muchas gracias a esa era por
estar en directo América Gracias a
ustedes por la invitación
Cuba Venezuela y Nicaragua están entre
los países de la región latinoamericana
que eligen su propio camino estas fueron
las palabras que dijo el propio labro
fue desde su parada en Venezuela sin
embargo es una visita muy cuestionada
porque justamente estos países son
criticados de antidemocráticos Usted qué
opina sobre la imagen que reporta en
este momento Rusia al hacer esta gira
con sergei
esta gira es una gira que podríamos
Llamar de diplomacia de guerra no y en
febrero labrof también hizo unas giras
similar por África con el propósito de
de restablecer y consolidar la
influencia Rusia rusa en ciertas
ciudades en ciertos países de África
donde ya son eh mantienen estrechas
colaboración y lo mismo sucede en
Latinoamérica Esta es una gira que no es
fuera de lo común a excepción de la
visita de Brasil la visita de Nicaragua
Cuba y Venezuela aliados de hace muchos
años o décadas de Rusia con quien han
mantenido una estrecha cooperación
comercial no y política y en área en
área militar por lo tanto me parece que
esta esta gira no debe verse Más allá de
lo que es una forma de consolidar El
Poder y rusa en lo que eran lo que son
sus aliados en el caso de Brasil es un
poco distinto no Brasil tiene un cambio
de mando con el presidente de Lula que
ha querido tener un rol más prominente
para mediar con la guerra en la guerra
en Ucrania no luego de las expresiones
que hizo en China pero vemos esto como
parte de una diplomacia no no tiene nada
que ver con un apoyo
un apoyo a Ortega o al régimen cumama
cubano es básicamente consolidar la
influencia y recordarle a los Estados
Unidos que Rusia permanece en
Latinoamérica no se ha ido y digamos que
esto puede servir de plataforma para que
en el futuro vuelva a latinoamérica a
reunirse con otros presidentes
latinoamericanos con los cuales Rusia no
tiene una estrecha colaboración pero lo
vemos en el marco de una diplomacia de
guerra que ya empezó en febrero con su
gira también en África con el mismo
motivo Aunque en África digamos que fue
un poquito más más extensa y así como
hemos visto pues hemos visto a los
funcionarios chinos y también a los
funcionarios estadounidenses moviendo
muchísimo La diplomacia Internacional
especialmente Pues ahora que ya no hay
restricciones de pandemia pero Zaira me
llama algo la atención y es que a
diferencia de sus paradas en Brasil y en
Venezuela sergei solamente pasó algunas
horas en Nicaragua Entonces
es casual O tiene que ver con el hecho
de que precisamente sea en este momento
Nicaragua el objeto de mayor crítica a
nivel latinoamericano en términos de
democracia
Yo pienso que Nicaragua no es muy
relevante para los intereses de la broad
también Ortega tiene una estrecha
relación con Rusia hace muchos años con
la brog el hijo de Ortega recientemente
recibió una condecoración del gobierno
de la federación rusa una medalla de la
amistad por lo tanto me parece que tenga
mucho que hacer ahí y tiene una agenda
bastante ocupada con la situación en
Ucrania por lo tanto yo creo que es más
bien una cuestión de de que no tiene
tanta relevancia y que ya hay ya han
habido visitas no visitas de distintos
dirigentes de Nicaragua también de Cuba
y de Venezuela en los pasados meses a
Rusia para discutir distintos asuntos
por lo tanto yo creo que es una cuestión
más de de tiempo y y no creo que
Nicaragua sea tan relevante para para
Rusia en en estos momentos más
relevantes Brasil que recibe una gran
exportación que importa
fertilizantes de de Rusia y es muy
importante para su economía del sector
agrícola y también más importantes
Venezuela por la situación del del
petróleo y por los acuerdos comerciales
y los préstamos que le ha dado Rusia a
Venezuela para mejorar la industria
petrolera Así que yo lo diría que que
tienen ya una relación muy estrecha con
Nicaragua y con Ortega y no requeriría
más no requería más de de unas horas
como una visita protocolar simplemente
como una visita a un amigo Qué fue lo
que al final finalmente sucedió es
interesante de todas maneras que América
Latina se ha vuelto en un objeto de
cortejo no por parte de las potencias eh
Ya lo decía hace unos minutos con la
visita de blinken y de funcionarios
estadounidenses a países
latinoamericanos con la visita del
canciller Chino también a países de la
región Y pues ahora llega el turno de
sergei labrov todo esto por supuesto en
el gran contexto de lo que es la Guerra
de Ucrania Así ha destacado la
importancia o el interés de desarrollar
proyectos de producción de petróleo de
desarrollo de yacimientos de gas de
agricultura de industria farmacéutica
etcétera etcétera y de nuevas
tecnologías sobre todo no Entonces qué
oportunidad ve Rusia en América Latina
para desarrollar no solo su influencia
sino su economía
sí tenemos que entender que ahora Rusia
se le ha encerrado muchos mercados entre
ellos uno de sus mercados principales
que era el mercado europeo Así que Rusia
necesita nuevos aliados comerciales
También necesita lugares donde hacer
inversión También necesita mantener una
buena relación con los países que no han
tomado una posición muy crítica en
relación a la Guerra de Ucrania y me
parece que igual que suceden África en
Latinoamérica los líderes
latinoamericanos no han querido tomar
una postura tan tajante en contra de
Rusia en relación a la guerra y ellos
están aprovechando esta oportunidad para
salvarse no porque obviamente Rusia a
pesar de que es un país inmenso es el
país de más extensión territorial
necesita aliados comerciales para sus
productos pero también tiene que
importar Y me parece que latinoamérica
es rico en distintos en distintos
recursos naturales Además de que es un
espacio de intercambio profesional Y
creo que eso es lo que está tratando de
cortejar en este caso no sé si sea tan
exitoso como están siendo exitosos los
chinos que tienen empresas comerciales
más desarrolladas porque el caso de Cuba
Rusia le ha fallado en varias ocasiones
en relación a lo del lo del petróleo no
Cuba está esperando mayor apoyo para su
para su abastecerse de petróleo esto no
ha sido así por las mismas sanciones y
por la dificultad de la situación actual
con Ucrania Así que hay que ver que
mucho de estos son solo promesas son
planes a largo plazo pero en concreto Me
parece que estos son solamente palabras
que se las va a llevar el viento Rusia
no tiene tanta capacidad de inversión
pero sí necesita mercado y mantener la
puerta abierta y La retórica por
supuesto Zaira Yo le agradezco esa era
Badillo Castro historiadora dándonos
perspectivas sobre la gira de sergei
laurofo por América Latina que tenga un
feliz día
Gracias igual y así es el momento de
hacer una pequeña pausa pero quédese ya
volvemos con directo a América
[Música]